buonasera a tutti
però mi avete dato veramente un titolo
molto importante
cosa sono le radici
dimmi chi ti dà vita dimmi dove vini e
ti dirò chi sei
perché le radici senza la luce senza
l'ambiente non danno vita
abbiamo tutti un ciclo vitale ed è
diverso per tutti voi pensate alle
povere viti che nascono in quelle terre
disintegrate
concimate chimicamente
che vivono con tutti questi integratori
e quelle che vivono invece di una terra
fertile
però è sempre più difficile trovare a
terra fertile
perché ricordatevi che quando sono
arrivata io sulla collina san gimignano
i preti erano pieni boschi pieni di
ciclamini di fiori di seta errati i
borghi sono stati distrutti dai suini b
non c'è più un ciclamino giro quindi
trovare ancora una terra veramente con
una microfauna la microflora in tappe è
sempre più difficile
guardiamole gli animali gli animali ci
sono quelli che vivono in cattività ci
sono quelli che vivono liberi ma anche
la libertà è sempre più
è sempre minore perché sempre meno ci
sono gli habitat liberi per gli animali
andiamo da domani ci sono quelli che
vivono la raggiunge e conoscono le leggi
della natura
ci sono quelli che avevano accettato e
della natura non sanno proprio più
niente
però tutti annunci profilare siamo tutti
diversi ma tutti simili c'è stato un
grandissimo uno dei grandissimi al
grandissimo 600 avanti cristo che è
stato il padre vergine già era una una
setta indiana che diceva che la materia
è lo spirito si uniscono e si rivedono
ciclicamente per formare i vegetali
animali umani cioè
siamo tutti la stessa cosa secondo loro
comunque adesso solo per ricordare al 6
nel seicento avanti cristo è stata un
secolo meraviglioso tanto bello quanto è
difficile è scuro il nostro
ricordatevi che nel seicento è nato lao
nel seicento un altro confucio in asia
in india c'era anche buddha a israele
c'erano i profeti in grecia c'è stato il
fiorire il primo fiorire di tutti i
filosofi dei primissimi filosofia che
era stato un secolo meraviglioso
comunque lasciamo stare tutte queste
divagazioni torniamo alle radici alla
terra alla vigna
io nel 65 sono venuta perché avevo
bisogno di portare dei bambini in un
posto libero e abbandonato meraviglioso
per la loro educazione che era la
collina sopra san gemignano
venivo la mia terra i miei antenati
vengono dal perbene toga veronese
lì c'è una terra molto molto ricca di
acque
molto molto totalmente diversa da questa
terra arida bianca che ho trovato a san
gimignano che era una terra di sedimenti
marini una terra di grande ricchezza
calcarea io per me il bianco veniva o
dalla valpolicella e la custodia oppure
dalla borgogna devo il mio dio ci
portava i vini quindi mi sono trovata
con una madre per i vini bianchi per il
calcareo e per i sedimenti marini e una
educazione un ambiente per i grandi
rossi perché voi mi insegnate è fatta di
rossi quindi ho subito pensato che fossi
trattasse di un rosso di vini bianchi la
vernaccia dovrebbe diventare un grande
vino
se veramente si seguisse la sua verità e
non una brutta copia dei bianchi da
altri luoghi
io li chiamo molto spesso one destroyers
quelli che credono di fare il vino in
cantina mentre qui non sappiamo tutti si
fa invidia
poi la cosa bellissima sono andata in
cima alla collina dove ho trovato tre
assi con la terra una terra rossa su una
base di roccia cavernosa che va
meravigliosamente bene per il sangiovese
però quello che io voglio dire è la
felicità di questi ragazzi che hanno
trovato la loro vita in questo ambiente
così libero così ancora pieno di luce e
senza costrizioni di nel suo genere
e poi voglio dire anche che dato che
vengono dal mondo di insegnanti e anche
gli agricoltori perché tutti i miei
antenati fin dal seicento da quando ci
ricorda fanno vino e sono state sempre
le donne a fare il vino è sempre le
donne a curare attentamente e
si consumava soltanto con il letame
delle mucche se si continuava perché era
un sistema puramente
biologico
perché la terra va bene il biodinamico
adesso è una moda di oggi
ma la vera realtà del biologico è quella
che vive una persona che a contatto con
la terra che parla con le piante e
comunque questo ritorno alla terra per
me è fondamentale anche per
riportare le radici umane ha un futuro
io ho preso due gruppi di case in cima
alla collina che vogliono destinare ad
anziani e giovani voglio raccogliere da
tutto il mondo
tutte questa meraviglia di ricchezze che
abbiamo ricevuto di tradizioni per
portarne avanti verso un futuro che non
è senza radici perché voi mi insegnate
che senza radici non si può andare
avanti e quindi non come dicono in
alcuni posti in america ha consentito un
waiver roots in the futures delle radici
non stanno nel futuro le radici stanno
nel link nell immensa ricchezza che si
sta perdendo adesso perché i nostri
anziani
portano con sé via per sempre
delle cose inestimabili che noi dobbiamo
mantenere e dobbiamo portare avanti per
un futuro migliore
questa è la nostra è la mia era il mio
scopo è la mia è
quello che ho nel futuro da poter
offrire e in avanti ecco questa è la mia
vita io quanto minuti ho fatto
l'ho fatto abbastanza
per oggetto il team
[Applauso]